what sunglasses this Casey nice that we
okay I always wear the same sunglasses
this isn't necessarily an endorsement I
mean unless Rayband you want to you
could call me but they are Rayband
folding Wayfair so they like fold and I
find the folding ones wrap around your
head better I've got a huge head so they
stay on better but then like the paint
and all that is that's more me not Ray
Ban what app did Casey and IAT make in
2015 my partner Matt Hackett and I
launched a social app called beam bem
and beam was like kind of like a
predecessor or a rougher version of like
Snapchat stories and unfortunately
Snapchat stories is just better we did
really well with the app but we never
had like the broad appeal of Snapchat
but starting that company making that
app was one of like the greatest
Endeavors of my life I love doing it